[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
she's sorry
[Music]
oh
[Music]
speedy
oh respectable man that's really good i
made some movies i'm not proud of
good to be here that was vulgar what do
you mean
i'm talking have you seen the movies i
mean you wouldn't be proud of them
either
all right so anyway good to be here
uh welcome to louder with crowder i'm
dave landau of course some of you have
heard of me most of you haven't
and joining me today in the studio we
got gerald
yo tucker now one tucking that one
i had to switch it up token that one how
you doing
not so tiny tiny tim quarter black
yo what's up and crawdaddy
train wreck part two yeah that's what
we're doing all the boards that you love
we're going for the going into the wall
anyway thank you guys for tuning in and
be sure to subscribe also
uh what else do we do we comment we
comment we go to the merch shop we go to
crowder shop we'll talk about that for a
second
you ring that bell get that yeah shirt
right there today we're talking
george washington without the teeth
jerks he had
a mix mash of teeth fine how many times
i got to explain that yeah he had some
people's teeth that worked for him i
shouldn't say worked
but yeah then he had uh you know wooden
teeth in there too
what a mess total i bet everybody stunk
oh can you imagine how bad everyone
smells like that
was a thing oh yeah just the breath of
him on top of you
oh i don't know why george washington
why did you go right to that
i just pictured barbara washington or
whatever
martha washington
you know one of the washington yeah one
of them knows
what is this the biden family one of
this anyways
they look like
oh man lineage good start yeah anyway
yes i think this is the third rail
yeah yeah is this is this literally what
he just texted me about
that okay well no we're not doing
anything no it's offensive
not on dave landau's louder with crowder
no nope
no sir well today we are though we are
going to talk about the term latinx and
see if hispanic people
actually do prefer it okay yeah and
hunter biden
also smoked parmesan cheese which is
kind of weird
we'll be uh we'll get we'll get to
clarence thomas uh the epic
concurring opinion about digital media
companies
and the allegations against desean
watson have you heard about this guy
no boy heck of a qb
[Laughter]
spoken like a true fan right is that how
you say it is that football
yes that's it's
qb is correct yes but with a name like d
shawn i knew it wasn't hockey
that's true wow there is one d shawn
yeah he drowned
okay moving on was a hot day
terrible it was very warm they didn't
understand you had to wait for it to
freeze
um you what position were you that was a
tight end
a tight end yeah don't you certainly
stop we'll keep that from behind the
paywall
anyway and finally we have exclusive
tapes from a phone call between
president trump and
former vice president joe biden really
how do you guys like that
i love it and again we're just going to
jump on it again the best way to support
the show is go to
crowdershop.com it's a live show monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern
mug club slash live chat comment
comment comment yes not right now on
youtube because you can't because you
are degenerates for the most part but
the people that are on the blaze can
chat and we'll answer those later on yes
hit that we love you either way i'm just
saying yeah we appreciate that you're
here
many fans yeah many fans from my old
show that are
garbage trash
and we love you and i do i love many of
them yeah
anyway and many of them i don't so
it's the opportunity to go away really
it's like a cyst
so uh breaking uh
breaking right now biden to take
executive action on guns
biden is going to issue executive
actions
on guns today i read that twice
i guess i shouldn't read the part that
says don't read
so anyway biden is expected to issue six
orders supposedly aimed at reducing gun
violence by requiring background
checks for ghost guns and red flag laws
what does it go what is it yeah what is
it
no i believe peter venkman had one
it's nice thank you yes yes
we'll have to look it up like what
technically is a ghost gun do you know
it's like a gun you make it
it doesn't have a it doesn't have a
serial number um oh is that what it is
legal to sell those now yeah they could
sell you an 80
lower and then you drill holes in it and
oh is that what it is and it doesn't
have a serial number i do
that hey we learn something every day
yeah yeah so that is what i buy out of
lunch bags
correct yeah tim has a few it does
i bought two off of them don't tell
anybody the guy's trunk is
filled with his hands that's just weird
yeah ghost guns
ghost guns yeah they're not real so you
got to reach them and you're like where
you going where's my hologram
then you just covered an ectoplasm and
you're like that's not
dope all right anyway so wish me luck
to sean is he here is he getting a trunk
later it's a little early
which makes you wonder who's running the
show here since during the democratic
debates
joe insisted on following the
constitution when it came to gun laws
well i mean i would just say hey joe
instead of saying no we can't let's say
yes we can
let's be constitutional we've got to
come yes we can
no kamala no he's terrible she is
annoying
oh she's haunting us oh geez she sounds
like she's crying
whenever she speaks it's a plaintiff
whale
yeah it's
i thought a whale different but she's
not heavy
she's very in shape and she flaps her
arms while making a point sort of
like a chicken that's right she's like
that's the eggs that she lays and then
is like kill it
so not literally it's no
no not literally just before it hatches
scrambling uh
so it's awesome that's enough anyway
uh roe versus wave versus kamala
it's also a bit ironic since we recently
found out joe biden's son hunter
lied about his past drug use to try and
buy a gun in 2018
wow which is a felony well normally
it's a felony not in this particular
case i guess because his name's joe
biden my son
i'm also finding this up now myself as a
gun owner
and it ended up in a dumpster next to a
school right yeah
yes it's just an adult well i think if
you're gonna throw a gun away
it's important to do it during near
school yeah i've always said that i
thought the great place
i thought it was like you throw it in a
river or a lake
probably what i do is i just paint uh
the tip of a real gun orange and just
hand it to any kid oh it's totally not
real
here you go it's it's not lotus and it's
like it is
loaded they do things differently in
detroit don't they they do it's pretty
neat well if you pull an orange tip gun
on a cop you're not gonna make it home
for supper oh
that's actually on our flag
[Laughter]
so statement a little wordy yeah it's
it's not a great slogan
no yeah that's why they came up with
pure michigan because tim allen was
tired
i'm going paint the tip orange come to
pure michigan and pull a gun on a cop
so question of the day will i get the
show canceled
yes likely is jerry's still out that's
still up highly likely
okay i actually uh the real question of
the day is
what do you remember from the hunter
biden story was it uh
was it memory hold for you
didn't just go away basically yeah
comment down below that's what i'm
telling the viewers
comment down below what do you remember
from the biden story
put it down there i don't care right
you're common i'm not you
i'm me i'm better than you
look at me and now look at you
you lose look at gerald he's better than
you
there you go all right he's a tall man
he is yeah he is i look at you in the
chair no you can't he's just sitting
there look at him
i've heard that more than anything else
i'm surprised by how tall you guys are
oh i always get the complete opposite
well yeah i don't ever get that
no i always get like wow you're short do
women talk to you
just your wife yes she's taller no in a
good way
everyone's job no it's fine you owed me
for that comment i made yesterday
yours landed better it's fine well it
hurt equally as much
[Laughter]
you've probably heard the new term
latinx going around
it's it's supposed to be a politically
correct way to refer to hispanic people
you guys have heard it it's like
genderless
i think taking it out though yeah it's
it's a gendered
uh it's to avoid a gender uh yeah
whatever it's not true i just don't care
it's it's uh it's hispanic people to
avoid a gender language which
i mean never mind that every word in
spanish is gendered right
anyway we decided to go out and ask some
latinx people
what they thought of the term
[Music]
latinx voters latinx community latino
a lot next person here's some spanish
101 that can be hard for people learning
the language
every noun has a gender language is
ever-changing and that's certainly the
case when it comes to defining people of
spanish-speaking origin here in the us
spanish is a gendered language and the
old favors masculinity
so now we have latinx the spanish
language is really gendered so
latinx is the gender-neutral alternative
i identify as latinx i mean obviously
everything that we were taught came
within the last hundred years
and it all came from straight white men
this notion that
any masculine presence in a space
changes the grammar of the language
assigning
importance to gender in a way that
communicates to girls and women that
their experience is
necessarily changed by the presence of
masculinity and when i think about that
linguistically and i think about the
implications on
a culture whose language has
that kind of hidden inequality with
regards to binary genders
despite what the media twitter and my
netflix queue has told me look
i am not convinced that latinx is a
thing that it's ever been a thing
outside of rich white women's circles
and so i decided
to check it out for myself with people
who actually speak the romance languages
nowadays they're talking about like
language that's offensive do you refer
to yourself
as latino latina or latinx
because now they're saying latinx is the
term is that have you heard that
latina latina latina okay
yeah because now they're saying latin x
is the new term they're using in college
did you know that
oh i don't know hi i'm so sorry this
might be a weird weird question um i was
asking her are you you look latino
okay are you a latin latin american
latino hispanic
are you are you a latina yes okay
the reason i ask is because i don't want
to be offensive you know i want to be
i want to be sensitive and what do you
prefer is the proper
terminology do you prefer latina latino
latinx
how do you i don't
know do you call yourself latinx
just latina yeah okay so latina's not
offensive
is that okay that's respectful if i say
latina american
yeah okay okay that's all all right
thank you very much i appreciate it
and since i'm a busy man i asked some of
my employees to go do the same
prefer the term latin or latina
uh as prefer to like latinx have you
heard of that
no no yeah it's like you don't yeah
okay
well now that's like the the like pc
term yeah i know you're supposed to say
latinx
i don't like that you don't like that
are you latino by any chance
yeah okay so question for you have you
heard the term latinx
okay ask and see if like what people
actually prefer
yeah have you heard that no i haven't
heard of that yeah latinx
i don't know no i told you yeah we're
trying to figure out if if it's like
useful to start using that
latino is good same thing you never
heard of latinx
mexicana i like that one just trying not
to be
you know but no x yeah no x
yeah they added that all right thanks
you know you know what i'm talking about
there's latin
x is like the new uh phrasing
no curious if people actually call each
other latinx
i don't really use that word
okay uh do you like being called latina
latino or latinx
what latinx do you like being called
latinx
like latinx have you ever heard of it
okay so you don't go by latinx okay
there's this term going around like
social media latinx have you ever heard
that
latinx it's like latino but like they
cut out the
gendered language i don't know do you
know anybody that knows what that is
prefer to be referred to like latinx or
latina
latina latina have you ever heard of
latinx before
have you heard of that
[Music]
hey have you ever heard
it's like it's like the new way you're
supposed to sit
matina or latin
it's never heard of it it's like
trending on twitter
and which do you prefer do you like
better it's just regular spinning that's
what we're just trying to figure out
like it's
you know you don't want to be offensive
you know these days i prefer if it's
like latinx or latina
latino like just to cover all the other
right because it's gendered right yeah
it doesn't really work in spanish i
don't i don't think it's not even like
the turn
either the one with the z yeah yeah it's
like an x at the end they cut off the
last part it doesn't work in spanish in
the way that the language
yeah it's good there's like
black people who are
speak spanish and stuff are transgender
okay okay so do you prefer latino or
would you prefer like if people used to
connect more latinos more
that's fine but if it was a transgender
person then they can't prefer like
they're a guy or girl probably
maybe not an ex maybe okay thank you so
there you go out of
everyone we asked only one
person prefer the term latinx was
younger woke more americanized
the pew research center has just
published its first
study on the use of the gender-neutral
term latinx
it found that most latinx adults in the
united states haven't heard of the word
and only about 3 percent use it to
identify themselves as an individual
what do you think have you encountered
people requesting
the term latinx in your everyday life or
do you think
that this deserves to remain in the rich
white feminist graveyard
[Music]
the rich whites feminist graveyard is
actually in los angeles
oh that's good to know is it on like the
the tourist map like
it is behind it yeah yeah if you look to
your left there's stop rich
you put flowers on just the men's graves
the male feminists oh okay that's a
thing did you know that support yeah
yeah so uh guys go ahead ring that bell
that's the best way for us to get
subscribers
along with commenting hit up that bell
hear that
that's a bell click it smack it hear it
smack it these aren't your old fans dave
these are our friends different crowd
yes slap it tug it what it's
yeah it's about what's the bop game yeah
stop it flop it yeah flick it
flick it rub it no no nfl player um
so story we'll get to it you'll
understand later you'll understand later
guys i don't know
about that qb qb yeah
i want my quarterback quarterback all
right
the song none of the women sang no no
baby back ribs
remember that chili's yeah of course oh
look at the classic
yeah and then you have the mick rib and
i've never eaten a mcrib i'm not it's
disgusting i'm pissed off about that one
they're seasonal the irish should be
offended by the mcrib
come on why would it be seasonal like
the animal that comes from
is in season yeah you understand the
green shake around uh
st patrick's day that makes sense yeah
up in the crib
i will eat a drink a shamrock shake all
day
that is a delicious treat now i said
i don't know if it's pork or cow the
mcrib comes from or the shape of a rib
it's a mystery meat
but yeah it's a very sick animal yeah
guess they have to wait for it to want
to kill itself and then they're like oh
it's in season
it's got a whooping cough all right so
it started cutting itself yes yeah yeah
get the marketing going yeah
it keeps running head first into a wall
like aaron hernandez
football yeah that's another football
player a tight end
is he a tight end well he was well yeah
i heard he had a
he had a couple lovers so anyway
yes uh cbs makes am i on the right part
right you are
yeah i don't know if you guys do know
that cbs has made hunter biden
the victim oh that's sad winter biden is
coming out with a memoir
entitled beautiful things uh named after
his niece's feet
and what am i wrong
very true it's very true and we can put
up sources
they'll take the video down with
crowder.com yeah we won't put up the
video it's actually a crime
um but and earlier this week he did
two cbs interviews to promote the book
did you say your
you and your dad talk every night every
night yeah
if it's possible to pull the politics
out of it i'm left with tremendous
sympathy for a family that has been
ripped
yeah and wounded by this i mean no
matter how good a parent you are or how
bad a parent you are this can happen to
your family and we're seeing it play out
in in a very public detail yeah it's
absolutely true if it helps them get
better i'm sure joe biden's all
for it yeah absolutely as a father he's
got family support for sure
came to my apartment one time and this
is when he was still in office
as vice president and so he kind of
ditched his secret service
figured out a way to get over to the
possible and i said what are you doing
here
he said honey what are you doing
i said dad i'm fine he said you're not
fine
so he he calls his adult son honey
i refer to stephen as sweetie my dad
called me sugar tits
he'd flick my nips
that was the punishment the flicking
that was it yeah oh yeah well it was
it was i'm glad i didn't go any further
i mean unusual it went on though for
days when you least expected it
wow it's like being waterboarded
except with nipples yeah i can't
understand now and of course
did your parents punish you of course i
mean look i
i have sympathy for joe biden and his
family you can be a great father and
sometimes really tragic things can
happen
i mean yeah a lot of you guys know my
sister was into drugs and i've talked
about this she has a great redemptive
story
um that's we grew up in the same house
right so things like that can happen i
think what
we're poking a little bit of fun out
here is that it seems like there's a lot
of weird stuff going on
in the biden household as well yeah so
it's not just that part
i think drugs are pretty normal but if
if
your dad came over to talk to her and
was like hey young man
like that's essentially what honey is
yeah it's a little weird
it's a it's a you don't call a guy that
maybe your mom
would call you that but yeah dead i'd be
like hey son like there's
like this father-son moment son you're
not okay and maybe it's honey honey
i don't know yeah that's just weird it's
just weird here you combine it with
smelling kids you combine it with
putting women on his lap but that you
combine
forgetting i'm just like i don't know
man that's a little strange
yeah he didn't know who he was talking
to he's like thought it was his wife
i thought my dad ditched his secret
service detail and showed up at my house
calling me honey donald trump jr gives
like a really
impassioned speech at the rnc and
everybody's like oh he must be on
cocaine meanwhile like we know
right yeah what hunter biden was doing
for effect what's the media talking
about
oh yeah you know did you see this the
the squirrely
shaky scared
that's what cocaine looks like and it's
because i used to do it and i had access
to mirrors
in fact i was looking at a mirror when i
would snort it
handy yeah they do well that's why you
have the mirror it's like you want to
look good
after you've powdered your nose it's
true
got it anyway in the quran
all right so and of course cbs grilled
them hard with the questions
and then there's this in 2014
the younger biden took a job on the
board of a ukrainian energy company
burisma holdings at a time when his
father who was then vice president
had an active role in u.s policy toward
ukraine
it raised eyebrows at the time but by
the 2020 elections
hunter biden was the center of a
political firestorm
hunter got thrown out of the military he
was thrown out dishonorably discharged
that's not true he wasn't
cocaine news and he didn't have a job
until you became vice president what do
you mean
he made a fortune in ukraine in china in
moscow that is simply various
other looking back did you make a
mistake
taking a spot on that board no i don't
think i made a mistake
on the board in october 2020 a new york
post article said that emails
reportedly showing shady dealings in
ukraine by hunter biden were found on a
laptop computer
that he supposedly left in a delaware
repair shop in 2019
the details were sketchy at best and
last month
a declassified intelligence report said
that before the election
the russians had launched a smear
campaign against joe biden
and his family it does not specifically
talk about your laptop
yeah was that your laptop i don't know i
know
you don't know yes or no if the laptop i
don't have the idea
i have no idea so it could have been
yours of course certainly
it it there could be a laptop out there
that was stolen from me that could be
this i was hacked it could be that that
was the that it was
russian intelligence it could be that it
was stolen from me
and you didn't drop off a laptop to be
repaired
in delaware not that i remember at all
well you were on crack
yeah so yeah we'll see i could have been
wanting more crack and sold it yeah who
knows
not that i remember i'm sorry that last
line we'll see
like we'll see yeah we'll see are you
finding out with the general public like
gosh i really want to see the end of the
story i have no idea how it goes yeah
i'll be tuning in
it's not like they already exposed it
and everybody pretended it didn't
happen yeah we'll see how it works six
months ago specific details from the new
york post are sketchy
yeah but hunter biden not so much
sketchy at best
his comments yeah and his comments were
just taken at face value
yeah those are they called sketchy at
best they don't they don't repute
anything that they've said because they
know it's true
and you know here's a rundown of the
events surrounding hunter's laptop and
the ukraine
energy board position twitter censored
the new york post
story on on hunter's laptop we all know
that yeah
claiming it was uh a hat it was hacked
information
yeah when it wasn't
oh i thought there was a clip there is
oh where was that funky music
well somebody's not on the ball and you
made that's a little mistake with new
york coast
we we cracked it out within 24 hours i
hate his face it was not to do with the
content it was to do with a hacked
materials policy
ah oh the hacked materials kitty porn
policies
[Applause]
so glad they're enforcing that yeah what
a terrible ugh
you guys remember when this happened
right so they banned them they was they
said we fixed it within 24 hours but
what they did is they actually came back
and said
no you can't have your account unlocked
again until you fix
the tweet by deleting it right right so
this is the new york post what was the
top five circulated newspaper in the
country
this was on the heels of i think new
york times leaking trump's
tax returns apparently and twitter
having no problem with putting that
story out there
and then he said yeah we were wrong for
taking you down but you still have to
delete the tweet because when we took
you down we weren't
we weren't wrong yet we hadn't realized
that moment in time
yeah so this is just some weird wormhole
we all kind of fell into for this right
it took actually two weeks for twitter
to get them back
yeah and running it's crazy and also the
guy who
owns twitter looks like he only grants
evil wishes
that's true oh no it's like a monkey's
paw thing yeah it really is he's just
not he's a wish master
just a creepy looking guy all right so
uh yeah he looks like a
amish guy on rum springer but he just
stayed there
i'm gonna do ecstasy just i'm gonna
start a media company
yeah it's gonna be great uh former vp
joe biden got a ukraine prosecutor fired
to protect hunter did you guys know that
that's another fact
i was supposed to announce that there
was another billion dollar loan
guarantee
and i had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko
and from uh yatsenyuk that they would
take action against the state prosecutor
so they said they had they walked into
the press conference
we're not going to give you the billion
dollars they said you have no authority
you're not the president the president
said i said call him
i said i'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars i said
you're not getting the billion i'm going
to be leaving here and i think it was
about six hours i looked i said i'm
leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor's not fired
you're not getting the money
oh son of a [ __ ] got fired
and they put in place someone who was
solid
oh blackmail yeah solid let's see if
they take the term blackmail out of
context
i love how these leaders talk about the
billion dollars as though it's theirs
it's ours it's our money
yeah it talks like he's got a checkbook
you know yeah it's not taxpayer money
he's a tough guy i like how he builds
himself up as though he isn't
just the vice president at that time
right one of the most least
consequential positions in the u.s
government other than you could be
president soon if something bad happens
that's about it just in case guy and who
knew something did
that's terrible it is amazing though
that yeah he just says that and
essentially the story is like you said
uh
talk to the real guy yeah yeah i i can't
do anything about it well
unless we forget donald trump was
accused of committing a crime by doing
what he did on camera right literally
amazing thing right it's amazing yeah i
don't know
hunter also had texts about face timing
naked with someone who is allegedly to
have been
14 yeah and close to him we won't say
who exactly
i already did but you can do your own
research
not hard to find no it's there's there
is information out there it was in the
new york post as we've mentioned before
and everybody went i still think it's
fine
it's okay they tried to slander tony
bubelinski's you remember that guy yeah
good name bubelinski
italian breadshow they tried
[Laughter]
they tried to slander tony bubelinski's
eyewitness accounts
of hunter's ukraine dealings as russian
disinformation joe biden had a at a
public debate
referencing russian disinformation when
he knows he sat
face to face with me that i was traveled
around the world with his son and his
brother
to say that and associate that with my
name is absolutely disgusting to me
i've heard joe biden say that he's never
discussed business with hunter
that is false i was introduced to joe
biden by jim biden and hunter biden
at approx and at my approximately
hour-long meeting with joe
that night we discussed the biden's
history
the biden's family business plans with
the chinese with which he was plainly
familiar
at least at a high level on may 13 2017
i received an email concerning
allocation of equity
which says 10 percent held by h for the
big guy
in that email there's no question that h
stands for hunter
big guy for his father joe biden
is he dead yet oh not yet i think
biden keeps getting to have him killed
he means to
it it just slips his mind
is quick the clintons you know no he
said he's always like who was i supposed
to suicide today
uh i don't remember the clintons have
better staffing you have to till three
[Laughter]
well they also uh questioned too yeah
yeah you know we gotta put that out
there they did
ask him why he banged now i want to put
this more diplomatically
dead brother's wife beau's death shook
the entire biden family but the way
hunter dealt with his grief
made headlines when he began dating his
brother's widow
after both
how did people look at you poorly
i think people were
confused disgusted yeah i understand
that horrifying i mean i really do
to me it's not something that is
difficult to explain
because it came out of a a real
overwhelming grief that we both shared
and overwhelming urge to do we were
together and trying to do certainly
the right thing and that
turned into a hope for a love
that maybe could replace what we lost
yes you had sex to replace your dead
brother got it totally makes sense
it is for you bro people were coming
r.i.p i'm taking
care of her don't worry she's in good
hands
[Laughter]
did they just start their relationship
after he died because one of the
overlays said it looked like the article
at the weight
immediately at the immediate at the okay
there's no way in my opinion
i gotta be clear yeah there's no way
there wasn't something before it's not
like you're at the wake and you're like
so he's not around anymore you got some
free time
i don't have trouble explaining this at
all it's uh
my understanding that you're single now
come on man it's like whatever what is
that
this is like wedding crashers just crash
the funeral yeah
funeral crashers
they're like could you just please go
every time somebody dies he just walks
in like hey
hey guys hey is that my relative's wife
here's what they didn't tell you he
cheated on her with a stripper
and had a kid with her wow and confirmed
with a paternity test
that's messed up bro yeah did you know
that he was finding hope
for a love that's true it would last
forever he was upset
that his new love's brother died
well husband husband but yeah his
brother
i miss the joke on that everything can't
be perfect
you know joe biden talks about these
poor grandparents that haven't been able
to hug their kids during covet
yeah mm-hmm he has two grandkids he
hasn't acknowledged
oh really oh yeah this is grandpa joe
with the stripper yeah right
yeah yeah i mean i wouldn't acknowledge
him either
if
i'm just saying if you showed up on my
door and you're like i have proof here
my daddy i'd be like hang on i gotta go
get a shotgun scare them to run away
yes like joe biden's no you really
should be responsible
and uh those are your kids hunter
your kids i realize you got to put up
with sparkle
but that's got to be the worst part is
having to have a
stripper in your home
could you stop stealing so anyway
these are your things this is
yours do you want me to break another
face no please no please please stop
trying to smoke
out of it anyway so conclusion in my
opinion
obviously addiction is terrible and a
crippling disease as you know i am an
addict but
the media is trying to ignore the
serious crimes alleged
by handing hunter a free victim card so
why don't you comment comment
maybe you disagree with me yeah i doubt
you do because i'd love to hear you
and i'm pretty discouraged but please
come and comment disagreement on youtube
i don't think that exists everybody
always says nice things that's what i
like about
that's why they tell people always read
the comments
that's what i hear yeah that's why i
read them to just great for self-esteem
yeah i'm always like i didn't know that
there were even that many gay slurs for
me
who knew yeah i wish i was kidding all
the letters
yeah every uh yeah there's lg go through
the acronym
double a-r-p plus minus
double a no triple a
i have triple a do you well if the car
breaks down you know
you need it yeah you call them up i they
changed my tires i was on the freeway
and give you the slurs as well free they
do they
couldn't change it well they're right
then when i can't even change my own
tire
scratching your head like but i don't
know i you know it's there i'm like look
it's
it's the middle of winter you do it
[Laughter]
i tip i'm like here's a 20 in there like
wow how we
i'm like go get mess so before he
walked over we actually forgot the best
part
uh he accidentally smoked parmesan
cheese wow
you would wake up some mornings i
shouldn't even say some mornings because
you slept for like 15 minutes at a time
and be looking for a crack and just
smoke whatever was there
yeah i uh you know i spent more
time on my hands and knees a lot of
corrections
drugs um smoking anything that
even remotely resembled crack cocaine
i probably smoked more parmesan cheese
than
anyone anyone that you know i'm sure
that's not funny so awkward yes
right you could not land with her
parmesan he's like this is relatable
right you just smoke stuff you find in
your rug
yeah barbie's one day am i right come on
you've done that
come on what no all right
next question yeah you know i am in
recovery and an addict so i i do really
feel for hunter here and i was actually
surprised to learn
there are a lot of addicts um wait wait
dude do you guys
do you guys smell that i do you smells
like a
smoked gouda it's here what's what's
going on hey guys
[Music]
i asked them not to do that it's no
laughing yeah it's not funny that that
smoking cheese thing is just it's a
it's a big problem a lot of people are
oding yeah oh
cheesing they find them over cheese
[Laughter]
it's like in uh what was that uh oh
never mind
the self-censoring of the players the
third rail just went by
speaking yeah so uh
it was uh i'm gonna get you sucka do you
remember that where they're like he over
gold
they feel like we're in 300 chains and
that's how he died
one of my favorite bits how'd he take a
[ __ ] with all that on
don't so on monday the supreme court
ruled
the case against trump i don't know if
you guys heard about this clarence
thomas
yeah you know more oh that's right yeah
yeah well no they ruled so it was
basically over him blocking a couple of
people on twitter and saying that that's
a violation of the uh the first
amendment right and then
but it was basically saying it was moot
and should be dismissed
yes but in his concurring opinion
clarence thomas suggested a few ways in
which
digital media may be held responsible
for removal of certain content so i'll
read just kind of a quick quote here
if the aim is to ensure that speech is
not smothered oh dave you went too fast
on the quote
oh it's not smothered i didn't know i
was in control of you
you're in control of everything oh the
heavens glaring concerns
per force which we need to look that
word up sorry uh
be the dominant digital platforms
themselves as twitter made clear
the right to cut off speech lies most
powerfully in the hands of private
digital platforms
the extent to which that power matters
for purposes of the first amendment and
the context to which
that power could lawfully be modified
raised interesting and
important questions well that was wordy
clarence
yeah i don't know what moot or
concurring means so here to explain is
half
asian lawyer bill richmond
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well dave moot and concurring opinion
are important
when talking about this case it's
actually changed names some of you all
may not remember what the actual case
was about because it originally started
as knight vs trump back in the
early parts of the trump presidency when
president trump was controlling his
twitter
account he decided to block a few people
and they complained
well now since that's all been under the
water under the bridge at this point the
case was continuing to go on despite
president president biden
taking office and now having control for
our sensible control of that account
ultimately the supreme court ruled that
the case was moved it really there's no
controversy anymore
because the person at issue donald trump
is no longer in office
but clarence thomas took this
opportunity to issue a concurring
opinion
it's one that is his own it's one that
he is allowed to publish to say
hey i have some usings and some thoughts
regarding this particular topic
and what's really interesting about it
is that it crystallizes a number of
different theories
about how big tech can be held
responsible for the size and growth and
control of the market
and what they really do when they're
making their enforcement decisions
to break it down there's a couple of
very basic legal theories
all of which i'm sure you're familiar
with even if you don't know the name
one of those is the idea of the common
carrier you have
buses trains lodging like hotels
each of those over a certain amount of
time went through the same thing
they're a private business should they
be regulated and for the common good
the government decided and amongst the
support of the people that
you should have free access and much
less ability to restrict
users that are people who get on buses
people that get on
uh toll bridges for example or even
hotels those became common carriers that
are subject to
more regulation on what they can
actually do to exclude because of the
essential nature of that particular mode
of either lodging or transportation
in a very similar analogy justice thomas
talks about how
social media given their large scale has
become a common carrier
there's drawn analogies between those
examples and how the need to communicate
to advertise even the sheer fact of the
number of officials
that are communicating on on platforms
in publishing
media units like twitter and youtube and
facebook
have just increased exponentially over
the years have made these
companies more akin to common carriers
and the method of communications that
they provide
now the second consideration is one of
public accommodation
there's long been a theory of law that
when you have a certain thing such as
uh entertainment that is generally
available to the public
it should be exactly that generally
available to the public
with more restrictions on what they can
do to actually exclude people who are
participating
while there's a couple of different more
legal arguments about which circuit is
saying that you can do it with physical
spaces or not in the end
we know that these big tech companies
have of their own admission
wanted to grow to become ubiquitous
within our society
that's how they make money but their own
growth has come with consequences
they've gotten to the level of being
public accommodations they've gotten to
the level
of being so big and so pervasive
within our as a mode of communication
both privately
and in official capacities that they now
must essentially
pay the consequences for that growth in
the end though
justice thomas admits that there really
is not that kind of case before the
court at that very moment
the case about biden's control now of
the trump twitter account when trump was
president
really isn't the dispute there but what
every one of us is thinking intuitively
is what justice thomas put down very
eloquently that these companies have
become so
big that their ability to control the
flow of information
their ability to close the doors of the
marketplace of ideas
or even worse secretly decide to keep
certain ideas out of the marketplace
and off the shelves for consumers to
consider as they go about their public
lives
is something a very big concern and
without a doubt there will be more cases
that come up
that deal with this issue on all sides
of the spectrum
that's why we have a lawyer see you next
time
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a good man he really is a good
theme song too i'm a little bit jealous
of that but
he made a few good points and we've
we've heard people talk to us before
about this and say look it's a free
you know free market economy you guys
should not have restrictions on what
companies can do
and for the most part that's accurate
until you reach a level where you become
the new
digital public square right so right now
if we wanted to go out and make a point
about something um that's controversial
and you know something that would never
ever happen right guys youtube would ban
it
twitter would ban us and also facebook
would ban us all in the same period of
time
on something that was kind of topical
that we were trying to talk about
that would keep us from having a voice
right so we could go and speak somewhere
right publicly and speak in a public
space but you've basically taken away
our ability to do it in the way that the
founders intended so what they were
talking about is look
people go over here you can go to the
public square you can say whatever you
want and you can reach as many people as
you want by doing that well not anymore
they have become the new digital public
square and i think it's really important
that these cases make their way there
but i think it's coming through the
states
i think once the states enact those laws
like you've seen in florida
i think we're going to see it in texas
as well soon here yeah
you're you're going to start to see some
people challenge it and then it will
start making its way through the courts
and it needs to happen because speech
needs to be free if the ayatollah
khomeini
can say death to all jews and still have
a twitter account
then i think that donald trump saying
something a little mean or a little bit
rude
probably isn't or fights right isn't
grounds for kicking him off of twitter
completely so
i think i think it's an interesting
point and i'm glad playing thomas
weighed in on
wait did you guys do that what is going
on
seriously guys it's my second
show
[Music]
hmm it's not okay those colombians never
yeah
i know they've been smuggling the cheese
in here and i've asked them not to
every time throwing them over the fence
he's colombian yeah is he colombian he
is
just dropping gently on the other side
basically yeah
on his head well i wish he would stop
we've talked to him and he just doesn't
care anyway so
i don't know if you've heard this story
is it desean watson
a q qb there you go yes
yeah back quarterback i just want to
call a quarter like that qb
yeah or black i don't know football
better so he does better
football the hell you just said i said
you're better oh i'm better
there you go i agree with that well if
you guys don't know uh
rely he's been well i i guess i
uh he was i'm trying to put this in
words that wouldn't give me
trouble he enjoyed going to massage
parlors right
i understand which who cares but the
problem is is the women
at the massage parlors claim that he uh
i guess he went to like normal massage
parlors and was like hey
i want you to do things do things finish
the massage
involving the the back door
well and apparently the front door and
all doors yeah the gluteus muscle
alive the gluteus muscle i like how you
put that i don't think he meant muscle
yeah the sphincter i think he meant
twixt in between
yes it betwixt yes
he meant the the the black hole
oh jeez starfish yes the
area where no one should go near on a
man no
i mean unless you want to i don't want
to well of course you know but he has
been now
now he's being i guess he can't go is
this right gerald
there he's moving from houston to well
so
he's he's one of the best quarterbacks
in league right for the houston texans
well it's still he can still play the
game that's not the uh the issue so far
not as relaxed yeah yeah no um but his
sponsors he's got some really big
sponsors rely on energy beats by dre and
nike and they've all cut ties with him
over this because that's obviously what
everybody's going to do right now and
there's not
it's not like a few women have come out
it's 22 women who have come out and
filed lawsuits against him
and and the team's trainer well yes
absolutely and
one woman actually he just doesn't know
what a massage actually is it's just
well you know maybe it's a different
definition for everyone i don't know
he's like i thought the butthole was
part of the massage thing i mean it i
i puck a lot well he's probably got an
achy butthole
yeah probably under a lot of stress
right now and you can't go relieve it
just sitting at home like why do i do
this yeah he's just using like two back
massagers
it's like something's gotta take me to
my special place
[Laughter]
so uh yeah one woman ashley salas i
think her name is claims
watson assaulted her while she was
trying to give him a massage
and watson's lawyer uh rusty hardin
no which is actually what no that's his
name rusty hardin which is actually one
of the things he asked for
uh how is that his name they're going in
front
going in front of judge rusty trombone
yeah rusty's lawyer uh no sorry
uh his lawyer rusty hardin said the
allegations were
she's a real lawyer real name why would
your real name
why would you hire him you're a lawyer
change your own name legally come on
yeah he he's very interested in the
paperwork and he can do it for free what
if he's a ginger
he probably is he probably needs a
picture of rusty hardin
esquire i'm rusty o'harden
[Laughter]
dropped my family came over to america
yeah i said
he said that the the allegations were
meritless and part of a blackmail scheme
which i will
give him it does seem like a very
convenient time
for all these women to kind of come out
of the woodwork essentially committing
crimes
and say that this happened it's just
very strange but
we uh we hey we aren't here
you know we're supposed to have a rusty
hardened photoshop is that right
i don't where's brandon i thought that
was supposed to happen did brendan
can someone please find brennan we're
supposed to have a rusty heart in
photoshop this is
what
[Music]
uh any you guys seen brendan anywhere
it's occupied
[Music]
is okay then so is this he's been
sharing cheezels
you never share your cheese cheese whisk
you gotta do it yourself well look
poor deshaun watson right potentially
but uh also
jerk deshawn watson potentially right
i'm not leaning either way i'm not
saying that these women
didn't have these things happen to them
at all and i'm not saying that uh
you know deshaun watson is a saint i
have no idea you're not a lawyer you're
not
you're not rusty i'm not i'm not mr
trombone
rusty rusty harden yes um i
i think if the timing is a little
curious he was about to sign
probably one of the largest contracts in
nfl history for a quarterback one of the
best guys out there highly sought after
by every team looking for a quarterback
and this comes out in the midst of him
trying to force his way out of houston
maybe he wanted out of houston because
he had all of these allegations
while looking around he's like i have no
more parlors i can go to they all know
me now well he wanted fresh meat
yeah something i have no idea but the
guy go in and they're like hey buddy
it seems odd and then the lawyer for a
lot of these uh women basically just
released
these claims with no supporting evidence
at all initially
into the media for about a week week and
a half so i hope
it's not true but i have no idea it just
seems a little suspect to me right now
it does
i mean we can't speculate too much you
know since i don't know all the details
yet but i mean in the meantime
uh here is the seven plus one new
endorsement deals for
john watson
number seven jack in the box well that's
obvious
okay low hanging fruit yes low head
that's what i pick
i i'm very short i can't reach the high
stuff
[Laughter]
so uh number six why don't we go to
quarter black
kleenex for design watch that's right
oh there's the translation yeah i gotta
do it too at the same time
it's a little hard oh number five what
do we got
all right he's co-starring with john
travolta one of your favorite actors
in the new movie pants off
i want his pants off
also travolta known for the massage yeah
that's what i hear yeah he's known to
have had a few yeah like mid-air when
he's the pilot and he walks out he's
like you're gonna want to
take care of this all right
who's on autopilot that's right uh
number four papa craw in and out
oh i get it fur burger oh my goodness
what
whoa wait you've never dropped a burger
on the carpet is that
no is that what it i don't know is that
one of those secret animal burger things
you have to order that's correct yeah
yeah is it in and out yeah they don't
have it on the menu it's a legit thing
yep okay it's true all right it's like
when you go to pizza places and you ask
for more than pepperoni you don't know
just guess
[Laughter]
number three traffickers table showers
who makes table showers because they're
only used for that
like nobody takes a table shower at home
you know i'm gonna go lay on the table
and
instead it's where 80 guys have been
before you and you're like yeah rinse me
off
[Laughter]
is this what will wash away my sins nope
negative number two ming's dry rub
oh it doesn't
it doesn't go on wet number one
what you got you want to do it this is
all you if you're uncomfortable
all right beat off spy andrea it's a new
one you got to replace the headphone
sponsor man
you know they're like beats by dre but
but no yeah
or handy yeah they're very handy that's
well done
line of the day thank you all right
number one though
and we uh is jerk soda oh and we
actually
have a commercial that he's filmed for
right i don't know if you knew
yeah he already made the commercial so
they can't really drop them since they
signed him i don't know how they knew
about all this but let's take a look
or not eventually
oh i know he threw the kid his towel
oh my heavens that's just not nice
that's seven plus one right yeah that's
seven plus one
thanks for watching
there's still one in the chamber i think
there's always one
and it always stays is it every time you
always forget them every time even when
you're done it there's
it's like magic even with russian
roulette pretty much
which they played yesterday well
playing prevented well prevented well
bill was thank the lord the bill was
here yesterday in the same outfit
i know by the way that's an iconic
commercial
and and i can't believe that they would
they would do it like that yeah what a
rehash yeah come on
um it's some creativity it really it's
strange too because it doesn't even
really
it just looks like his head yeah oh yeah
almost silly cut
off and the other ones but i mean it was
like we did it almost yeah
it seems completely they're better than
that they're better than that but
fortunately
when you come up with a last-minute idea
you have a crack team get it done
you guys really are amazing anyway i
don't know if you guys know this
journalists are still stuck on trump
yeah
last weekend brian stelter steltzer
how do you say it stelter is all i hear
okay last weekend brian helterskelter
and jim acosta discussed how they're
still recovering
from the trauma of the trump presidency
i'd love to hear from both of you how
dc journalists are adjusting to the
biden era jim this is your first weekend
anchoring here on on saturday and sunday
afternoons do you feel like your rundown
your lineup is is really different than
it would have been in the trump years
when you're asking me if i was run down
i thought you were referring to how i
felt during the trump era
uh no i think that you know listen uh
we're i think we're all dealing with
some post-trump stress disorder
wow wow you are fake dude i prefer the
guy in the middle on modern family
do you see his smile though there at the
end that is the smile of a super villain
yeah it is it really is he's diabolical
i don't know if we can pull it up but
it's yeah are you a big fan
crawdad they have just given up all all
intention of
objectivity it's just brutal to watch
well they don't have
a family they think they're a news
organization yeah they don't have a
villain
and that's why we have to watch the
board now we're who is that
is that the pepperidge farms guy is this
the george floyd tribe
it is it is yeah expert witness oh of
course here's this guy he wears the same
mask
every day and he's whispering
i'll tell you our cookies are the best
that's why they were inside of cup of
foods
oh no you could get nope
not only the physiology behind trying to
respirate
he's a pulmonologist so he's an expert
in this field but also he talks about
georgia
who isn't you you're not an expert in
this field yeah you're talking about
other people yeah
and you combine that with not just the
idea of the kneeling
but he adds a new element here the idea
of the manipulation of handcuffs red
rover
all right let's move on yeah what does
cup of foods even mean it makes me think
of sack of suds
remember from my cousin
it's just cup foods yeah like you go and
you walk out and you're like oh i got a
cup of meat
you just grab a cup as you go in it's
you know like with the the nuts and the
cake oh
like the yogurt fill it up with whatever
just anything strudel preferably yeah
if i'm in there cordon bleu
people always say dave you look like a
strudel guy
anyway cnn
cnn was probably too traumatized to
cover this but we here at louder with
crowder have actually obtained exclusive
audio
oh good from a leaked phone call between
former vp
joe biden and president trump president
harris's office this is
joe yes uh can i please speak to a mr
uh puppet a puppet
huh correct first initials i
am sure yeah i am
a puppet not sure let me ask does anyone
know
i don't have a puppet anymore
come on you stop calling here okay
come on you're a puppet joe a huge
perfect you just said it john hey come
on
listen let me tell you if i ever find
out who you are
okay i'm not when i get my hands on you
i'm serious i'm gonna pull out your
eyeballs
okay with the corkscrew man oh our
puppets in the habit
of using cord screws come come on guys
did you hear he said did you hear about
the corkscrew all right come on guys we
gotta change this number
and my diaper man he really does change
his diaper a lot
that's a shame yeah anyway when you
gotta go you gotta go yeah
it's true you know you gotta go right
now gotta go what's that jingle right
now
we're gonna go gotta go right now is it
depends gotta go get a good clip
jingles are we going to sing in this
title that's why they call me jingles
is that your stripper name it is yeah
jingle jingle i have two boys at home
that
are looking for their papa hunter oh
yes stripper it's tough times when
hunter has to hit the pole too you know
yeah well hunter
has hit the pool many times um so
what happened all right what
where are we shutting anyway you know
the you know the thing
comment comment comment yes comment
comment comment also come see me i have
a lot of upcoming shows and i'm going to
use this moment to pitch those
where are you at next i'm going to be in
port charlotte florida next week
las vegas nevada um i also am going to
have
dates at the addison improv and the
houston improv in june
that are going to go up but it's going
to be during the week so if people
happen to be in texas they can come hang
out
there you go i like it and then toledo
ohio
and uh yeah they'll be free for you guys
and stop throwing the fruit guys dave
has plenty of money to buy his own
vegetables
that's true and anything else he needs
vegetables just like biden
and also uh don't
don't do cheese guys uh it's a serious
thing
and if you want to comment down here you
can happily tell us how cheese has
affected your life
but until then i guess we should just
say to what to youtube
it's a cheese off cheese off youtube